foreign
[Applause]
Anna delvey was it November 22nd
at her home we were planning an
interview with her I don't know why I'm
like like my weird speech impediment
it's been a long day we tried to see her
in Rikers
she was in right on Rikers Island the
jail
did permit me to come see her
they know me there I think my name is
probably scribbled on a couple bathroom
walls there maybe I don't know but the
guards and the people that worked at
Rikers approved uh me to come interview
her there
um and it just wasn't working like it
just wasn't like it didn't make sense I
had I saw inventing Anna her Netflix
show that based on her life I watched it
more for Anders home he's my friend
because he came on to see his work on
that brilliant
um Shonda Rhimes like
I I didn't watch the whole thing full
disclosure I watched it just to like pay
respects to honors when he came on I
didn't want to be rude
um but I think her Sean does take from
what I gleaned was like this girl
regardless of what she did
she
revealed
sort of this white what white privilege
is capable of like how much you can get
away with if you're pretty and white
you know like I with no judgments like I
think you know and revealing that all
the friends that she
um that she implies I'm not accusing her
of anything I don't know what she didn't
do
you know when I've committed
made mistakes and I've done a lot of it
honestly like when I've lied I didn't
know I was lying a lot of the time I'm
not saying she lied but
like the point is you know
I'm going without judgments I'm
fascinated by
someone that was like
stuck in in this so it's just FYI
I
don't know what's going to be cut from
this like the lawyers there are certain
things that need to be cut for
um
jury I guess I don't know uh which is
essentially
I don't know because I can I if I'm
getting sued over if I say Purdue you
killed people in Appalachia by
intentionally getting them addicted to
opioids that's blasphemy
and slander technically they can sue me
for that
but I have umbrella insurance but I also
have well I'm a comic and the way I said
it it's satire
and it's what's the other one parody
so it's like I don't know if I say to
Anna like I'm the real con artist here
am I implying that she is one and if she
laughs is she admitting guilt
I don't I'm not smart enough to know the
answer to that I think that's up to the
jury whatever so the point is if stuff
has been cut that means it has to be cut
because it would influence a jury or
whatever her proceedings are
and
um we'll release it at some point when
the trial's over
like I think everything should be
transparent all the time it's just about
the patience of we'll release it when
it's time
um because I don't want to cost people
money or
it's not my business it's not my
business I'm just interested in
what she revealed
to us
which maybe all of you already know and
I'm just an idiot and I'm just like
catching up
like because I think that we are in a
system I'm not saying she's a liar but I
think we are in a system in America
where if
you're punished for telling the truth so
if you're poor it's impossible to get
rich unless you lie so people not
accusing people say she stole from Banks
okay
like let's say that's your
generalization
and this country
we only give people credit
if they literally and figuratively
already have credit like we give them
credit like it's not it's credit and
credit like they have to come from
wealth in order to be paid like Liz
Elizabeth Holmes her dad was rich her
dad Christian I just I copy and pasted
this on the teleprompter because I
wanted you to hear how stupid the name
is Christian Rasmus Holmes the fourth
one V is fourth
vice president Enron
so she got a lot of cred off of her dad
being already rich people went oh yeah
she's pre-approved let her in
forget the fact that it was Enron which
ended up being corrupt like it's like
Trump saying Trump's a good businessman
if you really look it yes he has
billions millions of dollars I don't
know how much he has but also the
business dealings were I'm not talking
about him as president I'm saying as a
business person you cannot refute that
his businesses were not you know it was
all
uh
would you call it rigmarole
um
so she benefited off that reputation
right so they banked on her because she
comes from money
they gave her they went this this person
in the waiting room who's black Hispanic
whatever I don't know your dad
her her dad worked at Enron so someone
must have read your like someone already
you you come here like I'll hear you you
know I'm just saying in order to get
rich you have to get pre-approved
first how would someone born into a low
class A send their class
if they don't
pull a magic show I just called a magic
show I am a con artist like that's
what we do I had to lie
and then I had to make it true but so my
thing was I'm gonna earn this but I have
to start off conning you
so you give me the chance to prove to
you that I'm not a con artist but like
you're not going to give me the chance
unless I lie
so what choice do I have
I told a man at 25 I walked in the
biggest manager
um
Comedy Club
you know Bearcats walked into his office
and I said
I I don't even know how I did that like
I truly don't know what happened
but I was like I'm gonna be
a famous comedian
so ridiculous looking back
and
I told him that I had done I never done
stand up I told him I had
would he have taken a meeting with me if
I said I hadn't probably not maybe I
don't know who knows
who knows like we all have to lie on our
resumes sometimes so that the lies on
our resume can eventually become true
I don't know if that's right or wrong
I'm just admitting that I've done it and
my thing is like if I got something I
didn't deserve
now I'm gonna fucking earn it and also
like
if you don't lie on your resume everyone
else is lying so like
do you blame the bell curve or do you
blame the person that's just trying to
like oh so I'm gonna be over here be
righteous and do the right thing while
everyone else is winning doing the wrong
like I don't know it's like the Lance
Armstrong thing it's like everyone's
doping
like
if I'm who am I cheating myself or I
don't know is that part of the rules of
the game I don't know
do we hate the player do we hate the
game it's like that old what is that
Chinese finger trap chicken egg I don't
know what the best thing is I'm just
interested in
talking to someone
and letting everyone have the
opportunity to hear someone out in a way
that's not like you have seven minutes
you have two minutes you have clip clip
clip like it's just so complicated like
I'm interested in what happens at the
Confluence of like internalized
prejudices
you know I'm obsessed with Russia you
know this about me
the the r the Russian of it all with
Anna played a lot into it when we go she
perfectly fit say she did everything
She's accused of doing
fine I'm more interested in
why we want this to be true
I don't know if it's true or not but why
do we want it to be true like what's
going on
in our biological basis for behavior
that makes us want to sober like that's
interesting to me so being a woman
I'm not I don't believe in gender
whatever
we've been socially constructed to go
blonde woman
like
a lot like tricky
like was the reaction Fair that's all I
ever want to investigate you know
um
if it was fair why if not why when I was
in my 20s thank God I didn't fucking
have social media I would
do what I would have done if I could
manipulate people with social media in
my 20s I ca like if I was born any later
I would be
whoo like if I saw social media as a way
to like
you know I was doing focus groups and I
was doing making money and manipulating
people other ways to try to like get
ahead and
you know I S I don't know what she did
no one knows the facts like but I'm
curious like did she plot this heinous
crime or did she do the best she could
with the tools she had to survive to
achieve her dream which
that gets into like was it well it was
she wanted Rich to be have purses and
like okay but you can't judge someone's
dream we don't judge athletes that want
to put a
play with a
piece of plastic really yeah like why is
that dream valid and someone that a girl
that wants a Hermes purse not like I
don't know why we like think that
football players are like that's a valid
dream
but like can't I don't know aspirational
dreams it's a tricky one you know like
maybe she deserves it maybe she doesn't
I don't know like why do we all have to
participate in your fantasy I I don't
know
it boils down to like
did someone do the right things for the
wrong reasons or the wrong things for
the right reasons
like I love that like I don't know the
answer I do the wrong things for the
right reasons all the time
I smash people's car windows if there's
a dog inside
it's wrong to smash someone's car but if
there's a dog or a kid inside like you
know and sometimes I'm like hey why like
it's like when someone is
shitty like about your baby in public
like hey your baby you're you're not
gonna watch like that person is
doing the wrong thing but kind of for
the right reasons like I I hate that you
just doubted me and micromanage me but
like
like you're cool like I kind of fuck
with you even though you just pissed me
off and just judge me and we're shitty
like that was you're a cunt but like
yeah I used to think only intention
mattered but now I think in Impact
matters too this is a choice I've made
in your 20s you don't work I didn't
worry about impact in my 20s it was like
by my that's not what I meant
that's what you do I didn't say that
I never said that
like that's what you do that's what I
did
like I I took responsibility but that's
not what I meant
but like
the person's still hurt you know what I
mean it's like if a drunk driver hits
someone they're still dead
like you didn't mean to do of course you
didn't sign up to kill someone that day
but you did
you know so it's like we don't we don't
think about that in terms of our
under the influence of programming under
the influence of
ancestral shit I know and social trauma
make fun of me uh under the influence of
the neurochemicals you know we're drunk
driving we're drunk moving through the
world but it's a different kind of
inebriation it's like
you know I'm Dr I'm like I need to be
liked and we're crashing into people you
know so it's like I don't expect anyone
under 40 to care about impact at all or
until you have kids but like it doesn't
matter
like parents it doesn't matter who
spilled it but we have to clean it up it
just doesn't matter I have to keep my
ego super in check like on a daily basis
like when I defend myself that's my ego
it's shame it's just like but I'm a good
person but no no let me like let me
explain
it's like
and I think that I had a Epiphany
recently of like
ambition is ugly people don't like when
someone's ambitious it's sneak it's like
it rubs them the wrong way it makes you
know so
if ambition is a crime like I think
Anna's guilty and so am I
like I'm an ambitious bitch
someone recently said ambition saved me
future
like ambition is my drug and it's
my ambition what I want to achieve is
ultimately I think I think who knows
like please call me out
my intentions are always like I want to
get all this money to redistribute it I
want to put money back in West Virginia
I'm going to give it to animals I'm
going to save elephants like I'm greedy
I I hope it's all clean for good you
know
so that's my ambition but like
ambition's ugly a lot of people use
ambition for selfish shit like I don't
know why Bezos needs a yacht that
like who's like why is anyone on a yacht
it's like my thing with surfing like I
know it's fun I got it
fun but like I'm sorry I just I had to
sit through the fucking 100 foot wave
documentary and I love someone who's
obsessed with something I I I'm that
person I'm a fucking dog with a bone I
am a tenacious bitch when I want to get
an elephant out of a fucking zoo it's
there's nothing like I am you better
fucking you just have to give up I will
not give up
but like
surfing it was like is this all just so
some guy can go wee
wee for 20 seconds all this for that for
that was it like was it that worth it
and like
we're all just being like okay okay does
the guy get to go wee wee for 20 seconds
like what's who's who's this for
what's the like skill like what's the
service
like we could all just go home and like
we don't have to do this none of us have
to there's no other ways to be
entertained now like did you know about
like
like there's other things to do we could
be doing anyway and adelphy I'm so sorry
girl
um maybe your lawyers made us cut so
much out of this that this is the only
part of the episode this just is the
episode at this point I just I do
believe in second chances I sometimes
believe in third chances you know I I
I think learning publicly is cool and I
think that we're in a place where we're
all going to be learning publicly now
because we're all posting stuff on
social whether you have 10 followers or
10 million we're all learning in public
and we're all going to grow up and have
to look back and go I made a lot of
public mistakes
and you're going to be publicly shamed
even if it's around your town with 10
people oh my God remember when he did
this five years ago remember when he
fucking dressed up as this for Halloween
like we're all famous now
whether it's with five people
gossip Rumor Mill like it's all the same
whether you're the tiniest town in
Toledo
or your Reese Witherspoon like it's the
it's the same feeling
like when those celebrities can't relate
to right it's like they feel the same
thing now you know
but it's just on a smaller scale it's
all the same you know and so
public shaming people I think is good it
serves a purpose in society in the tribe
you know to show what's right and wrong
so I'm always into people that make
public mistakes because it makes it sets
the example of like oh we can't do that
you know I'm fascinated by the forensics
of the aftermath of like why everyone
had the reaction they had so I also
think two things can be true at once you
know you can be someone that lied before
and now you don't need more or you can
be someone that you know did a bad thing
that wasn't from a place of bad
you know I think two two things can be
true at once you know I think we hurt
people by accident all the time we're
we're all doing what we were programmed
to do until we actively deprogram
ourselves so unless you're trying to
deprogram yourself you have the
self-awareness whether you're listening
to podcasts like you know huberman and
Rich Roll and Lex Friedman and like this
this Consciousness moment of like oh
I kind of want to like
um wake up I kind of want to like
like unwash my brain brainwash I want to
unwash it and like see things from
different perspectives because like the
media just wants us to or not in the
media like
you just here's the point of view the
one thing I think there's a lot of
people are like I kind of want to hear
every side and then I'll let you know
what I think after like we're back to
having to
we're back to the three Network system
it's like CBS NBC it used to be three of
them and now it's like back to just one
of them people just go to One News
Network and they they got only one point
of view it's like I think people are
actively like can I hear all sides of
this and then I'll make up my mind so I
just think if someone is doing what they
were programmed to do whether it's their
ancestry addiction running the show
Neuroscience social construction to
survive plus having a big dream like
who's to blame who do we I'm always
interested in who do we blame and so
this conversation is
uh more of me talking a lot
um we talk about the Rachel the girl
Rachel the friend I know you guys are
probably going what about the friend
that they went to Morocco like we
addressed that
um you don't have to agree with me like
I play all sides on this I'm like I'm
trying to get from her what she did
wrong so wrong she's not allowed to
admit a lot of it obviously but like you
know make up your mind you don't have to
agree with me
um
I'm an Entertainer I'm a comedian I'm
not running for office I'm not your hero
don't ride elephants and here's
Annabelle
Anna delvey I'm in Anna delvey's
apartment I've never been happier
this is a dream how are you feeling Anna
I'm great how are you I'm good
um what update just give me a status
update on how you're feeling your
current situation you've got an ankle
bracelet on it's very it's actually very
chic thank you and you went this morning
to ice just to check in yeah that's
right they just like texted me last
afternoon so we had to like to switch up
all plants a little bit but it all
worked out thank you so much for doing
this I think we've been trying to
organize this for a while I was going to
maybe come see you at Rikers we like
couldn't
figure it out I didn't I didn't want to
come see you in Rikers I feel like I
would have run into a lot of my
ex-boyfriends
you just wait until she's out of there
um so how have you been since you've
been able to you know kind of be out and
about
uh well I'm really grateful for the
opportunity that I'm finally out because
I was kind of never really a given so
um yeah I'm pretty happy I'm finding it
out because yeah I just never I didn't
really expect for the judge to ground my
bail to be honest because he took like
weeks before to decide so you're
technically on house arrest right and
then how long does this go for I mean
forever until something else happens I
don't know I don't have this expiration
date for that until like my immigration
case plays itself out pretty much and
that could take anywhere from like a
couple months to a couple years pretty
much and so you uh how much was the bail
it was only ten thousand
um but my other conditions are pretty
restrictive which is like 24 7 house
arrest other than like going to report
to my criminal parole into my eyes
uh are you allowed to drink
ah yeah yeah I'm just curious you have
to take urine tests or blood test
um I'm not supposed to be taking any
illegal drugs and I don't but I don't
have I don't have any restrictions on
alcohol interesting yeah
um so I'm just gonna say this
uh on my way here uh this girl
recognized me Bronwyn what's up girl and
she stopped me and she was like I'm a
big fan I love you whatever and I was
like okay I'm about to go talk to Anna
Delby for my podcast and she was like oh
my God like I've interviewed a lot of
famous people super interesting people
super talented people super funny people
and when I tell people I'm talking to
you they lose their minds like there's a
fascination with you that is so deep and
there is a I would it's like a reverence
and kind of a
um obsession with you and I said to her
I was like can I just run
my hot take on antibiot really quick
just to make sure I'm not losing my mind
and I was like
I'm not exactly sure what happens we can
get into it but like I'm like I'm not
anyone that kind of fudges numbers to
get what they need from a bank I'm not I
don't have a soft spot for banks you
know what I mean I'm not big on like but
the big
what about that poor bang you know what
I'm saying and it's also I was like
didn't she kind of just reveal how
superficial and shallow everyone else is
in a way and also when I was 25 I'm not
accusing you of anything
I lied on my resume you know what I mean
I you know so I'm just curious like you
know do you how do you feel people feel
about you
um because my guess is you probably only
read the negative comments or only see
the sort of nasty shit but I've talked
to a lot of people who are like yeah how
else Are You Gonna Make It in America in
your 20s without a little smoke and
mirrors
um yeah so it's I don't know it's
complicated I obviously like I read a
lot of like comments about about myself
like on your post and Daily Mail well I
used to do it on social media back when
I had it last year just FYI as the woman
you're gonna be called a lion cunt
whether you've lied or not yes that's
just part of the does being a woman you
might as well just do it because people
are gonna accuse you of it anyway right
I agree
that's fine
that's what I thought too yeah it's like
I'm a lying whore regardless so I might
as well lie and sleep around
yeah but yeah there's not really much
downside yeah
um and I mean the rest of it is like I
don't know I feel like a lot of people
just know me from this the Netflix
series and I feel like it's kind of a
caricature and um
I don't know like sometimes it feels
like they kind of know this person that
doesn't really exist in a way so I don't
know it's really hard to kind of like um
evaluate people's perception of you it's
like what information they have so they
make those judgments you know because
you know there's just so much out there
so you know it's like funny when I meet
a person is like oh did they didn't know
XYZ because they kind of assume they
just know everything because it's just
so easily accessible right right or they
know very little and I think that I
think that everyone's perception of us
is like 10 us and 90 a projection yeah
of their insecurities or seeing
something in someone else that they see
in themselves that they don't like or
it's a distraction of look over there
look over there and don't look at the
things I'm doing you know that are shady
you know I think it's a Confluence of
kind of all of that but I tend to think
that very little of someone's perception
about us has to do with our actual
Behavior yeah yeah yeah yeah and a lot
of people like would tell you something
just because it's like for example they
failed so they'll tell you like you'll
fail to so it's like every time every
time I take somebody's advice or I don't
know this opinion you also have to take
into consideration what that person the
position that person is coming from sure
yeah sure it's really um yeah not
everybody's like opinion or advice is
the same and so can I ask you like what
do you feel in terms of the last 10
years is there anything that you regret
in terms of like decisions you've made
or choices you made I regret pretty much
everything I did until about two years
ago so I just no judgments yeah
well I kind of feel like um regret is a
lot of like looking back and not
accepting who you are today and it's
like I don't know obviously I regret a
lot of decisions but I just don't get a
choice to like press a button and go
back and redo it so I'm just trying to
kind of figure out the best way to move
forward and not
um kind of like to um I don't know make
the best of the advantages and like not
kind of let the downside be too
depressing yeah well let me just ask you
I'm going to jump around a little bit
because I just want to kind of frame
this with you know sort of my point of
view and my sort of take on what I've
seen like when I first kind of heard the
story which I'm sure anytime someone's
like we telling something
not even second hand a millionth hand of
you know when you sort of like exploded
onto the Zeitgeist you know and I you
know when I hear about something so much
I don't really follow New York rich
person gossip you know but
um you know it was impossible to not
hear about what happened with you you
know and uh and you know what I heard
was basically oh this girl basically you
know fudged some numbers lied a little
bit in order to raise money for this Art
Space and I'm like yeah isn't that just
being a business person like what like
how else are you supposed to get money
if people don't already think you have
money that's how to Make It in America
like no one gives money to poor people
they won't they'll only give you money
if they already think you're rich and
I'm like to me the art world no
disrespect it's it's largely based on
hype right it's largely based on hype
not to say certain art isn't good but
that's all subjective so it's like
you know to make it in the art world you
have to be good at hype so you hyped
yourself and your idea in order to get
people to give you money so I'm like if
this girl is good at hyping things that
makes her perfectly qualified
to be in the art world
because it's all based on hype pretty
much yes
so I I don't I'm not like I don't know
I'm kind of I guess it's I guess I'm
saying you know I'm also the person who
when I was 24 went into the biggest
comedy manager in the world's office and
said I'm going to be a famous comedian
yeah that wasn't true
by any stretch of the imagination but
you have to say something that's not
true in order to get people to believe
in you and then you make it true later
yeah that's that's you know I just think
you did this in the wrong City come to
LA and you you shouldn't have done this
in New York you should have just done it
in LA because people in New York have
like this shame thing or there's like a
more there's some morality bullshit
going on here where people pretend they
have like morals I don't know I just I'm
trying to understand how you're any
different than any other business person
or any other woman trying to make it in
their 20s I guess I guess you have to
like ask the District Attorney's office
um so you know let me just ask you like
when you when you look back it's like
you know
I think that a lot of what you did uh
accidentally was you embarrassed people
people got embarrassed because that you
know when I look at I'm not comparing
you to Liz um Elizabeth Holmes but when
I heard the Elizabeth Holmes saying it's
like oh she you know Henry Kissinger she
conned him out of half a million dollars
it's like well why the fuck was Henry
Kissinger giving some 18 year old blonde
girl who hadn't even graduated sophomore
year of college anything why did he even
take that meeting yeah you know so I
think that that's when things get that
get complicated you know I'm like is she
the asshole for promising you that she
was gonna follow through this technology
are you the asshole that gave some hot
blonde girl all that money when you know
there was the pitch wasn't even good you
know so so my question is like you know
when you look back on this are you kind
of like oh I just did this at the wrong
time with the wrong people or I sh like
how else were you going to accomplish
this goal of yours how else could you
have done it it was like uh kind of like
those years were big on like this whole
hype thing and like fake it till you
make it just kind of like yeah
like the early to the 2010s definitely I
mean I don't know it's just like I mean
there are some limits to what's
acceptable
um which you can and can't do I mean
legally but it's a lot of it is about
perception too
um and I guess a lot of this actions
like for example if she were like if
Elizabeth host for example if she were
to succeed she would have been like
lauded for her yeah yeah
like you know she did some very shady
things I have like lots of hot takes on
her
um you know ultimately it no the fact
that no one
said anything when she was getting you
know all this money and spending it on
publicist to get her on the front of
Time Magazine but it's also like that's
the game you have to play in order to
get more money you know who's to say
that if she hadn't had five more years
she would have pulled this off who knows
you know so I think that like there's no
doubt in my mind that you would have
executed your plan if you were just
given a little bit more time definitely
it's my best I mean look at like what
they've done with this building now with
281 Park Avenue South that's exactly the
same thing when I was planning so it
just kind of like goes to show that I
didn't just like make some make up some
bullshit it was never visible so it was
always but it's wild to me that people
would get upset with you because you
dared to have these big goals and Big
Dreams
uh coming not coming from
old money whereas if someone comes from
old money and they have not uh lifted a
finger they haven't hustled the way that
you hustle they don't have the ambition
you have they'd be like oh yeah no you
deserve this loan because of what your
grandfather did and old money I mean
name one old money billionaire that did
something that
aged well in terms of it being moral be
like yeah no you invented
um you know you founded Exxon Mobil it's
destroying the world and your
grandfather did something actually it's
like underpaid his workers and fracked
and ruined the environment you deserve a
loan even though you are just coasting
off of your you know grandfather's
selfishness like I it just you know to
me in America it drives me nuts that you
know in order to get money you have to
come for money no one wants to give
someone without money money yeah having
money that you didn't earn pre-qualifies
you for having future money you know so
I just I'm the kind of person that's
like I don't I don't come from money and
I'm just like how am I supposed to get
money or opportunities if I don't lie I
had to lie on my resume I had to lie
about having money that I didn't have I
had to pretend I had money because no
one wants to give some without money
money but then how are you supposed to
get it yeah create my shit you know
that's where there's so much inequality
people are like mad at you that you
didn't just do it the right way and be a
gold digger and fuck some old guy for it
you know what I mean like what how else
would you know you have accomplished
this goal otherwise this episode is
sponsored by betterhelp now
I know you know that therapy works so
I'm not going to convince you the
therapy it seems that you already know
it works I think it's more a matter at
this point of you guys knowing that you
deserve it for yourself and that you do
have time I think there are a lot of
people like therapy's amazing you need
therapy and you need therapy and you
should do therapy and therapy is great
but they're not doing it for themselves
you know so if you're listening to this
and you think everyone needs therapy but
you I have news
when you point one finger at everyone
else you point three back at yourself
see that and if you're just listening to
this you don't see that I'm making a
little handgun My Second Amendment right
means I get to do this
I'm making a tiny little handgun if
you're thinking and look I just made a
corny joke and I don't feel bad about it
because I've been in therapy therapy
might be for you if you're thinking of
giving therapy a try better help is a
great option it's convenient accessible
affordable and entirely online get
matched with a therapist after filling
out a brief survey and switch therapists
at any time you do not have to be
monogamous with your therapist when you
want to be a better Problem Solver
therapy can get you there visit
betterhelp.com Whitney today to get 10
off your first month that's better help
help.com Whitney and if you don't know
how to spell help you might not need
better help you might need Hooked on
Phonics or Rosetta Stone
ritual I started taking ritual four
years ago I've never had more energy
I've never felt better I struggled for
the longest time with these like weird
ass fish oil pills and drinks and
probiotic like like ritual nailed it
when people run around with their fish
oil pills and they're burping up Wharf
and smelling like Chilean sea bass all
over your those pla how dare you people
like we outlawed secondhand smoke why do
people just get to burp up sturgeon
in a meeting because I need my omegas
like cool buddy but like can you not
bring your bluefin tuna breath in here
ritual has those little mints in it so
you're getting your omegas without
having
a warfy ass breath I loved Finding Nemo
don't want to find him in a work meeting
when I'm talking to you ritual has
totally changed my life and now uh it
has something called symbiotic plus
symbiotic plus and ritual are here to
celebrate not hide your insides there's
no more shame in your gut game that's
why ritual is offering my listeners 10
off during your first three months visit
ritual.com Whitney to start ritual or
add symbiotic plus to your subscription
today yeah I mean not everybody who's
like successful is like a criminal or a
whore
are you sure
name one person
who then
I guess yeah I just I'm happy to be
wrong but I'm just saying like I just I
feel like we're all kind of you know in
our 20s you know we were taught to use
the secret we're taught to manifest
you're taught to fake it till you make
it you're taught to think big and you
know I I just I mean I've talked to you
a couple times I've spent some time with
you you're don't seem like a dark
Sinister person it seems like you're
bright and sunny and optimistic and the
difference I see with you is you don't
seem to move through the world with a
Darkness or a manipulative energy you
have a very bright and sunny innocence
to you yeah that seems like in your
heart of hearts you're like yeah no I'm
gonna figure this out I just need a
little more time definitely yeah yeah
that I guess that's that's one one of
the big misconceptions was like where
they just portrayed me as being like so
manipulative and like everything just
has an agenda and well you're young and
you're beautiful and you're blonde
and I'm a criminal you know yeah it's
just I think that it's just sort of
usually the people that do this just are
men and you're like oh that that's just
good business I don't know and you also
kind of are like the perfect casting of
like a Marvel movie villain you have an
accent you know from a very early age we
were taught like a Russian accent means
nefarious
would anyone have like like you know no
one would have given you a loan if you
had a Southern accent
it just wouldn't have happened
you know what I mean it's just like yeah
like this bitch knows some shit I don't
know it's like in a way when someone's
like foreign we're kind of like oh yeah
they probably have
do you know what I'm saying yeah I agree
with that it's sort of like the perfect
storm of playing into all of our fears
all of the stereotypes of women that
would be manipulative and conniving and
Serpentine and you have beautiful blue
eyes and Perfect Skin and it's just you
know
I don't you know I probably would not be
able to like to get away with it in
Europe
because they're just like well their
Banks don't have any money
not anymore yeah you know so I don't
like accuse you of anything what do you
feel like you know in terms of the
criminal charges what do you feel like
is like Fair like that is true I did do
that
um
well I can't comment on that because my
criminal case is still on Direct appeal
but um just having me for the system
myself like I'm just going to answer
something completely different oh yes I
like that I respect that
I've never learn from you I'm literally
just here to learn it's like that's what
I do sometimes it's like people ask me
one thing and I just answer something
completely different well I respect that
you know and I'm the idiot that answers
the questions people ask me and it gets
me in trouble all the time someone asks
me something I say the answer and then I
get canceled this is smart you're doing
what the guys do
you have a lot of control in the way
that you carry yourself you can Port
yourself with a lot of
you know competence and you're
sure-footed and you make eye contact and
it's you know it's it's a little
disarming my voice would disagree your
voice but then you have no I said my
lawyers oh your lawyers okay okay so
they think that you're that oh like 99
of my interviews are just awful why I
you strike me as very um direct well
maybe not yeah well that's the problem I
guess
I think it's refreshing
yeah
yeah I guess yes and you also have you
know like
I'm just gonna say this because I just
say what the fuck I think um and uh
I mean you and I have been kind of going
back and forth and trying to arrange
this for like a couple months so I've
had a you know a little bit of
experience with you and the way you move
through the world and the way you
comport yourself and I have absolutely
no judgments about it it's actually
inspiring to me
um I would say in the last six months
two or three people on my team
fully just work for you now
[Laughter]
I'm not even joking it's like wild
I can't I have a chief of staff I don't
like to say assistant because she's not
assisting me in doing things she does
things I can't do so I see Chief of
Staff not assistant Katie like she came
in the other day
can it I've never seen her have this
sense of urgency she's like Anna just
sent me this picture of these flowers
that she thinks should be on the table
when we shoot should I do overnight so
where do I get up we gotta get her these
flowers I'm like can I get my boarding
passes can I get my dry cleaning like do
you
like my credit card's getting declined
and can you call Chase Bank and help
like but like Anna wants these flowers
she needs these flowers she wants them
and then I'm like she's making demands
like that's what and then I read the
email and it's not a demand you just
were like hey I have these flowers in my
house right now they look really good
maybe we could get them for the podcast
recording it was like a gentle
suggestion and the way that it filtered
through her brain was like if we don't
get any of these flowers we're fuck it's
just like I don't know like
she might fire me I'm like you don't
live for her you work for me why I've
never had you handle
and then I get here this morning and I'm
like oh well you know no need to have
flowers it's fine don't worry about it
and then this morning she's like hey
just FYI on the flowers
and then I went to a little Mart and I
got flowers and they weren't the ones
you sent the picture of and I was sort
of like I think I'm gonna get these what
if she doesn't like them I mean you you
do have this sure-footedness about you
that I don't know if it's a you know uh
cultural thing whatever but you ask for
something without shame in a way you
just have these like brass balls that in
America people like you know what never
mind I'll do it like women in America
are sort of and maybe other countries
too I just want to speak from my
experiences like we're uh we move
through the world in an apologetic I
don't want to take up too much space I
don't want to ask for too much I'm
already pushing it just by being here
and How Dare I ask for anything I want
yeah and it's confusing to people yeah
and
it um it's kind of like an you know I
mean most the women I know are in
therapy to be able to ask for something
as clearly and directly as you do in the
worst you could hear is no it seems like
you're very comfortable with hearing no
but really I'm that doesn't mean I'm not
gonna I'm just gonna ask for it yeah and
if someone says no I'll just ask for
something else or go somewhere else you
know I mean I just learned it from men I
guess yeah you're kind of just doing
what guys do but you have the audacity
to be beautiful and blonde and Young
and I think the rest of us are like how
did she get away with that it's like I
kind of just asked right yeah that's
what I think like yeah I'd never like
really like made it like any scheme up
like I would have just asked and it's
like if
that's okay like they they did it and if
not you just move on to something else I
guess number three like I don't know I
didn't watch the Netflix series but
I doubt like any like the kind of the
whole chain of events really kind of was
portrayed the way it actually played out
because they were just like so many more
moving parts and there's just so much
more going on other than like this kind
of caricature the point of view of it
was more that your friends were shallow
assholes that were using you it was sort
of the point of view was more
um well why did they want to be friends
with her so bad when they thought she
was a
Rich heiress and then felt betrayed but
they were the shallow ones that wanted
to be close to you yeah because they
thought you had money I mean it was very
you know to me it's sort of like
people can say no if you if you the girl
the in Morocco or whatever like you
asked for something she could have said
no yeah you know what I mean
kind of thing yeah and she's the one
that said yes and then
was a felt like a victim and had to sort
of paint this sort of um I was swindled
and I was stolen from but it's also you
were the one that wanted stuff for free
yeah and then if she wanted something
for free she's the shallow asshole kind
of thing yeah that was kind of the point
of view of it was more that you held a
mirror up to everyone else's shallowness
and it embarrassed them and made them
look bad yeah I mean although up with
that I think yeah I definitely agree
with that but it's also like they kind
of over blew this whole like feuds that
haven't never like took place and just
mainstream media that laugh like pitting
people against people women against each
other of course it's like that's just
what that's just like such a big story
that doesn't even exist that Rachel girl
I mean this situation was really
unfortunate like I did promise her that
I was going to pay her back and I did
not not because I was skiing like a
scheming to do that or planting like it
just happened yeah
um and then she kind of like rolled
which by the way I got loans in college
that I did not intend to pay back I had
no intention of paying back the
University of Pennsylvania it's just I
had eventually had to you know like
there's a lot of money that I borrowed
that I had no intention of paying back
so you're already way ahead of me in
terms of getting into heaven
um and I don't know and then she just
kind of like rolled with a story then um
she was kind of reacting to what media
was like but she was also in the media I
mean she was worked for Vanity Fair
right so that's already someone who
wants to be public in some way or
participate in the muck raking or
whatever yeah absolutely and then she
was kind of like yeah kind of like went
there even though and now it's like a
big Rachel Feud me and her is like I
really don't care I could not care less
about her right it was just like never
that deep or serious it's just like
ridiculous they were like I had some so
many more deeper relationships I didn't
even like make it into the series right
right right well that was the one that
was just made the most public so yeah
and that's just I guess another
example of like
what Society chooses to focus on hmm
and so let me ask you when you you know
not making any accusations but in terms
of
getting loans from Banks like what was
your process in doing that am I allowed
to ask that
um sure I mean um I don't know a lot of
I don't know with me I was always like
oh this option is not working then we're
gonna like get try another one and
there's always another person who's like
willing to listen you out and like maybe
do something about it and like none of
them are doing it for selfless reasons
it's just they're trying to make a
profit yeah yeah and it all goes on to
the um reports and I don't know like
nobody's really like
she's doing it for out of the kindness
of the heart that's interesting because
to me you know
Banks I don't have a ton of sympathy for
banks when someone's like oh this person
took a loan from A bank and never paid
it back or oh this person you know
presented you know an exaggerated
version of what they had in order to
procure go for it
thank you
um
well let me back up here where do you
think the rumor of the German heiress
came from it seems like that's that
really caught fire was that something
that you feel like sort of was
insinuated and then it sort of
snowballed is that something you feel
like came out of nowhere is that
something you feel like was just like a
rumor or is that something you feel like
you sort of like leaned into and then
you know where do you think this heiress
thing came from because America is
obsessed with old money obsessed with it
um oh definitely so I think it came from
the DA's press release when I got
arraigned
um I like I've read it when they just so
I got extra edit from uh California
right because I was in Malibu and about
29 days later yeah that made me wait the
whole month so like New York they have
like 30 days to come and get you when
another state is holding you
um so they did I guess they waited until
the very last day almost
um and taught my lawyer at the time he
like showed me the email
um when he spoke to me before that and
yeah this is like where it came from and
in DA's office they're just trying to
like embarrass you as much as possible
and like see what sticks and I guess
that's they created it that never ever
came out of my mouth
so can I ask about the LA stint I read
online somewhere and everything on the
internet is a true fact
um that you were out there in a
treatment facility yeah can I ask was
that a getting sober thing I don't have
any drug addictions or alcohol
addictions no that was just literally
um I was there with a friend yeah okay
nice yeah and then did you enjoy la
um I like Hawaii for short periods of
time it's really bad
he would fit in perfectly out there I'm
telling you you just did whatever this
is in the wrong City
in L.A you would rush it but so okay so
when it comes to the getting loans from
a bank you know
and I'm someone that doesn't have
sympathy for banks I think when people
talk about you and getting loans from
banks in my experience they have more
awe than judgment but like she was able
to get this loan from A bank you know
and I don't have a lot of sympathy for
Banks Banks are assholes these are the
same people that when I was broke and if
you overdraw your bank account twenty
dollars they charge you a hundred
dollars in an overdraft fee so fuck
Banks but what was your strategy going
in to get these loans like did you feel
like it was pretty easy to get a loan
because I think what you did whatever it
was
held up a mirror to how fucked up the
banking system is which is if they
believe you have some kind of old money
to bail you out they're just going to
give you a loan whereas most small
businesses you know can't get one yeah
I guess it's like
so it's hard to kind of describe
describe it in one sentence but I mean
they know they have like this system set
up and they know what needs to be done
to bypass it so and if it's in the
interest to kind of like make things
work they will
assist you in every step of the way to
make sure it gets done and and then did
you like what do you think was in it for
them like did they because you had some
recommendations from other people or
they just you know align with your
vision or you think that they just like
why why do you think they I think it was
like it was like 80 000 here sixty seven
thousand there right oh well I mean I
guess the end goal for them would be
like for them to just have that count
with like the whole um like for the
whole business you know like to hold I
don't know the letter of credit for the
building that
um I've been trying to lease you know
it's like would we just love whatever
seven million just sitting in the bank I
mean I don't know like none of that is a
big money but maybe
um for like a banker just to have an
account like it kind of like maybe a
small entertainment Bank like I don't
know City National Bank maybe how did
you learn all this like how did your
your 25 26 yeah I would not have known
how to go going to a bank and even
who did you look to who did you get
advice from at that time well I had
great glorious at a time and it's like
if you just kind of like look into that
none of that is really that complicated
I don't know it kind of made sense to me
because your thing is to just ask the
worst I could hear is no
um
kind of yes I mean like it just made
sense to me at the time I mean I had to
like I had a great team so it's like
it's all was not even really me I think
I just kind of like knew which person to
pick and I guess that was like I really
like if you look at the team I had at
the time they were really great in terms
of the team like the bankers or like
lawyers Architects food and beverage
developers like a lot of people that go
into that no like no bank will just give
you money if um you just tell us to go
hi hey I'm a little girl like give me
money like they want you to have people
who will be responsible to so you had
already aligned with people that were
respected in the space that they all
wanted to be in business with pretty
much yes
and um I guess and it's like you just
have to see who would be the best one
and not everybody whose name is like
maybe in the media doesn't really mean
that they're good right all the time so
and then so it's sort of like aligning
with people whose reputations are solid
and it all kind of works together that
way I mean not even like I wouldn't say
I was writing anybody's reputation and
just like would see who would be the
best for the vision
I'm just trying to figure out what you
did wrong I'm not sure I'm not trying to
be an asshole I'm just genuinely like it
seems like there's the personal stuff
with the friends which is like you know
to me that's personal shit and you know
the thing I bump on with people being
you know getting their panties in a
bundle about your friend that's the
Moroccan trip or whatever it's like in
in this country or in most countries if
you're a hot girl who is you know
expecting a man to pay for your trip as
long as you're having sex with him
that's totally fine yeah but if it's a
friend and you sort of just overshot the
amount and had the intention of going on
this fun trip and then you know you're
sort of like
um
you know you know couldn't follow
through with it yeah which is you know
in your 20s you kind of just jump off a
cliff and try to catch yourself that's
just what the 20 your 20s is figuring
out where the walls are and what the
boundaries are and making mistakes and
learning from them but when it comes to
the financial institutions that's where
I'm just kind of like yeah what did you
do wrong
um
I don't know well I've been accused of
misrepresenting I guess though
my assets how else are you going to get
money in this country if you don't
already have it you know I mean yeah
just like we'll go look what what Trump
is being accused of doing right by the
AG so I don't know yeah I mean if you
were a man we would have elected you
presents of the United States so I think
your biggest mistake is that you're a
pretty girl
you know with an accent and we've been
trained from Bond movies to believe that
this accent is like a conniving you know
Insidious
you know snake
so okay so let's go back to the bank
stuff so
um you know do you think on some level
one of the things that went sideways was
you
embarrassed men I find when men get
embarrassed that's when shit really hits
the fan
oh well I mean my ankle was like to kind
of build my business not embarrass man
but
I don't know yeah I guess in a way
definitely I mean who wants to really be
put in that position right and I mean
not everybody really deserved what
they've got in the media like I don't
know
um one of my like lawyers I had it was
really great he didn't really like he
just like wanted to help me and that's
it that was his biggest kind of
um
that's all he's done and he just like
got so burnt in the media and like I
wish that didn't happen but kind of
everybody else I don't know they had
like they modest when I was in my 20s I
will admit I was manipulative I I didn't
know anything else I you know you know I
would dress the part I would try to look
cute for meetings I you know tried I
would wear a low-cut shirt if I knew I
was meeting with a guy that I'd heard
was scummy like I absolutely
that was and it worked you know what I
mean
um you could argue so I'm not accusing
you of this I absolutely owned that I
felt that when I was in my 20s I had to
do that you know I was like if I was
going in a meeting with the man I would
put my hair down and put on some lip
gloss that was going with a woman I
would try to like you know de-gender
myself and so that I didn't feel like I
was trying to be sexy you know I just
absolutely
um you know would shapeshift and walk on
eggshells trying to accommodate someone
else's ego and I was just kind of full
of shit if I felt like someone was a
narcissist and a you know egomaniac I
would compliment them and bullshit and
say that I loved their movies and their
work even if I hadn't seen them at all
you know whatever that
is what I did in my 20s good bad moral
not like I'm you know I have big
huckster energy I have big like you know
because again how else are you gonna
make it if you're not it's watching
People's egos kind of exaggerating if I
had done a guest star on a show I said I
or a co-star I'd say I did a guest star
you know did you feel like going into
any of these meetings you you know
dressed a certain way carried yourself a
certain way uh to be taken more
seriously was that at all part of it I'm
just curious like you know people really
focus on the way that you dress in your
fashion sense and was that ever
something that you feel like was an
intentional way to get people to sort of
trust you or feel like you already had
money therefore they didn't have to
worry that you needed them does that
make any sense I would always dress down
I would never like dress up for meetings
ever
um and I don't know what it came from I
guess it's just like now that I look
like now that has been over on analyzed
in a media by so many people I guess
that's what I've been thinking because
what would be the other explanation but
yeah I don't know it just kind of like
came naturally I don't know it was like
no big strategy I don't know I guess
yeah literally this is why it's so hard
to kind of like answer some of these
questions because it's just like I don't
know and look I'm the first person that
is you know in my not this special the
last special you know I did this uh bit
about how um you know Frank Abagnale he
was the guy that catched me if you can
was based on like if a man is a con
artist you know he gets a movie made
about him starring Leonardo DiCaprio he
makes a hundred thousand dollars to
speak at colleges about how he swindled
you know he he
um posed as a pilot he you know posed as
a certain like and now he's this like
here he did a TED Talk and everyone
loves it you know and uh how when men
lie we just think they're good at
business they're good at strategizing
they just have to do what they have to
do in order they accomplish their goal
and when a woman lies you know were
these it's like I knew it you know
that's why there's no female magicians
like no one likes it's not fun to see a
woman
hide something when a man does a magic
trick we're like and when a woman didn't
doesn't matter I knew it how would I
tell him they're all lying cunts so um
I'm just curious like because as I'm
talking to you there seems to be this
like innocence of you know like I just
had the you know audacity whether it was
planned or just you know learning how to
move through the world I just kind of
asked for all this stuff looking the way
I look and
it everyone is projecting on you that
you had this like calculated Insidious
you know strategy yeah right I wish it
would be like some alternate reality to
see like what's going how like I would
have ended ended up if I like literally
go a guy so I don't know yeah that's
just never going to happen so you know
when I think that something wild happens
when someone exposes how easy it is to
sort of like
reveal the house of cards that is you
know the New York Social Scene or the
New York banking system you know how
easily you were able to show how biased
it is how maybe racist it is and how you
know being white
and pretty can kind of get you a
ridiculous amount
or a ridiculous amount further yeah
yeah
definitely
hahaha
I mean this is the other thing it's like
the less you say the more I want to just
give you stuff like she's just I'm
blathering on I'm the con artist like I
you're just you're not you're just like
yeah no
you're like a gerbil wheel totally like
I mean here it's just you know it's just
fascinating can I ask you a little bit
about being from Russia sure I'm
obsessed with Russia obsessed with
Russia so much so that all my hair is
Russian
um I stand with Ukraine but my hair is
Russian
um I also have this theory that Putin
can't be treating his citizens that bad
if the hair is this healthy I mean look
at I mean not one split end from all
this Russian hair obviously you know
they're getting fed over there
um do you remember your time in Russia
how do you remember how old you were
when you went to Paris from Russia or
France oh I went in I went to Germany
first all right sorry
um I was like 15 so I was like traveling
with my dad when I was like 13 14 and uh
I was like homeschooled for a year and
then I kind of moved when I was 15. did
your dad homeschool you
um pretty much yeah oh I like a little
bit yeah that's interesting you were
homeschooled but did you ever go to a I
don't know I was just like homeschool
for like one year
a year I think in between yeah you know
why I'm just homeschool fascinates me
um ah because I just didn't want to like
get started on the new school while I
was about to move it was something like
that and so
just so at 15 14 you were like I don't
want to go to school and they were like
no problem
well I like finished
of the mandatory minimum but like we had
to do I think it was like eighth grade
and then I was like homeschooled for
like about half a year but the
homeschooling was your idea yeah so okay
I now know everything I need to know
at 14 15 you're like I don't want to go
to school and your dad was like no
problem
why would you not move through the world
after that not thinking you could do
whatever you wanted whatever you wanted
well went back to school and when I
moved to Germany oh God
sorry like 13 years of school okay
yeah
I mean
wait I have a question why wouldn't you
just move through the world thinking you
could get I mean it's just like I don't
know why you would have any reason to
believe you couldn't control authority
figures by just asking in a very direct
way and then doing this cute little
laugh that is so endearing and Charming
I don't know I mean you know the the way
to get what you want from Men in power
is just laugh at their shitty jokes like
this is why I I'm just telling you I
like like the world is divided between
women that last it guys jokes that
aren't funny and ones that don't I do
not laugh at guys jokes that aren't
funny and it is a real Obstacle of my
career
like if I could do this I would have
everything I want
it takes a lot out of me
if you fake orgasms too you will take
over the set oh my gosh
I used to drink quite a lot but it was
funny no
um
well I don't know it's like you know the
first time you realize like your parents
don't have all the answers and it like
goes all downhill from there yes that is
fascinating do you feel like you realize
that in your teenage years yeah I think
I was like I don't know maybe like 10 12
years old I remember do you remember was
it a specific moment
gosh I remember like the concept just
like thinking well maybe then maybe they
don't really know what's going on and
then did you feel like in that moment it
was like I need to take matters into my
own hands like you know these authority
figures
don't deserve the authority they have or
I can't rely on them like I have to rely
on myself yeah that was like kind of
kind of the seeds of that thought it was
just like well I better like have it
figured out for myself or nobody else
will
that's that's intense I mean I I had
that at a very young age I grew up in
you know
um an alcoholic home and mine was more
like oh I have to feed myself I have to
get myself to school I have to get
myself home from school you know no
judgment with you guys but I can't rely
on you yeah yeah yeah but it's like if
you already want to take care of
yourself like nobody else will
that's big and I don't know there was
not not one single event it was kind of
like gradual I think it was like kind of
the sum of observations
that's intense and like do you you know
not to disparage you know your parents
but like did you feel like they just
weren't around they weren't reliable
um no they were around they were
reliable it's just like just maybe what
they chose like wouldn't be necessary
would have chosen for myself like I
wouldn't have made the same choices
um
like the the moment I knew I couldn't
rely on my parents is when I asked to be
homeschooled and they said yes
for me like because that's what we do as
kids is we test we test the to see how
strong the walls are we're constantly
testing and it's just sort of like if
you don't pass the test of being more
Alpha than me then I have to take
matters into my own hands but I'm gonna
start laughing at Men's jokes
look what you've driven me too
a life of laughing at Bankers oh that is
child abuse
pretty much I mean in a way yeah
um I don't know like my parents kind of
like they because I was good at school
at the very beginning until I was like I
don't know 16 17. and I guess I just
like they thought I know what I'm doing
so like they left me a lot of freedom
and she's got this yes well that strikes
me as like uniquely also very Russian
like don't they just give birth to you
and put you in an igloo and like you
have to figure it out
so I'll have like a little brother he's
almost 13 years younger than me okay and
I guess he got like a totally different
in bringing from me even though they
have we have exactly the same parents
a different upbringing from the parents
or because you were involved in helping
me rear the child everything because
when my parents had me when they were
like relatively young and my mom was
like 23 or something 22 and they had him
when I live in L.A where that's very old
that's basically a geriatric and she had
him when she was 36. oh wow yeah
um and I feel like just the amount of 36
it would was he an accident or do you
think he was planned I guess he'll do
their every woman's eggs are frozen
of how cold it is I did not want to have
siblings I like that I like that you're
the same
so no one wants siblings
she just has the balls to say it like
who wants to share with some fucking
baby
I really wanted to have a sibling when I
was like eight nine like seven eight
nine I remember I was like a baby coming
into the mix when you're like 13 or 14
is that's so annoying and now we're just
like no
because then you're you have to babysit
it right yeah I want to call him like
your son it was also totally and it's
also like like you're just old enough to
know what sex is and you're like you're
fucking like you guys fucked in the last
year like why it looks gross like it's
just like you're supposed to do it when
I'm like eight there's four so we like
don't really know until later how he
came about
pretty much yeah
yeah
um so yeah I don't know like I just I
feel like they kind of missed a window
for me like not not to become like as
selfish as I am today because they were
focusing on this useless baby you know
and then you were right at the time of
13ish when you would need the most
discipline or the most kind of guidance
I guess yeah yeah and then I also like I
lived just with my dad for like about a
year or two and then it's just like
literally it's kind of like living by
yourself you might as well yeah you
might as well just be here
you just have to like survive somehow
yeah because it's also at that time at
13 14 you start like needing tampons and
they're just like bye like die like dads
are just like just but just here's a
thousand dollars go buy the tampons like
I don't want to hear anything about this
this shampoo and conditioner it's called
I originally got obsessed with it
because of the packaging I didn't really
care if the product worked or not I was
like I worked so hard
to make a soothing beautiful home for
myself to live in and I am so sick of
great products coming in packaging that
makes your
bathroom look like
um the bathroom of strip club just went
through an earthquake like I don't want
my bathroom to look like a CVS I don't
want it to be La I don't want neon green
like why are you yelling at me this is
these are the bottles that I want in my
shower they soothe me they make me feel
good they make me feel mature and I like
they're cute they're just the perfect
amount of chubby cherubic and very chic
this is the only shampoo and conditioner
that has repaired my hair and made it
luscious luscious and also I like to
floss with pieces of my hair and I'm
finally at a place where I can floss
again with my hair
so I know that's a weird endorsement but
you know when sometimes you need to
floss and you get a couple pieces of
hair and twist them together
if it breaks
now what discover all the ways to share
Joy this season the way.com and use code
Whitney to get 15 off your entire
purchase that's 15 off your entire order
at
t-h-e-o-u-a-i.com code Whitney look how
spot this is such big Spa energy grow up
way
um men and their t-shirts I don't know
what happened I don't know why you guys
who did this was it Stephen Dorff like
who ruined who made men think that their
shirts have to have long V's that I have
to see your sternum that they have to be
off the shoulder guys now have these you
know what it was fucking
um Maroon 5 Adam Levine ruined men
ruined them broke men Lenny Kravitz
Lenny Kravitz oh God Lenny Kravitz can
do whatever the hell he wants how about
that okay
me I would baby okay Lenny Kravitz and I
went to Nobu for a business meeting
people thought it was a date and let's
keep it that way
true classic think about those words
true that's a hot word classic true
classic the only thing hotter than a man
wearing a real t-shirt that just covers
what it's supposed to cover
cuts off what it where it's supposed to
cut off is a man that wears a true
classic shirt at 25 off at
trueclassic.com
Whitney free shipping included on
purchases over 100 that's 25 off at
trueclassic.com Whitney Santa won't be
the only one slang thanks to True
classic
you seem incredibly self-aware is this
stuff that you just sort of figured out
on your own do you talk to a therapist
or did you kind of just
um not just read like a lot about myself
in the media
no I don't know I don't go into therapy
I mean um like you kind of like Get I
got a taste of it like having been for
the system and not for me I don't know
not that this
um not at this point because I feel like
a lot of it just like when you keep
talking about your problems you think
like they become important and not all
problems deserve to be like being talked
about to that extent and you just did
something that made me like you a lot
but most people
you know you said I'm I'm selfish and
it's very everyone is incredibly selfish
but no one says that like most people
pretend they're not you know
um and that was really fascinating to me
that you just kind of said that without
shame you know the way yeah most people
go like you know I'm addicted to this
thing so therefore I seek things to feed
my ego they'll kind of say it in a way
that you know minimizes being selfish
you know I mean I think that we are at
Peak selfish right now and whether you
go I'm gonna get what I deserve and you
know I should believe in myself it all
boils down to being selfish and I don't
think there's anything wrong with being
selfish you know I think a woman being
ambitious or selfish is still something
that's really unattractive to a lot of
people or
um it triggers people you know I to me
when people say I'm ambitious it's still
like the nastiest thing you can say oh
she's really ambitious and she's just
like you know and it's whether it's you
know socially constructed whether it's
the biological basis but something rubs
us the wrong way when women want too
much or think they deserve something
yeah yeah oh like sometimes it can be
both too it's like they all go together
it's like it doesn't just because you're
selfish it doesn't make you like
automatically automatically bad right
it's like you can also kind of use that
um
for something better too it's like it's
not not everything is just like so
simple and one-dimensional and flat
right two things can be true at once
yeah I think people really struggle with
that I think the black and white
thinking really suits people and I think
people want to be able to say that
person's trash that person's amazing
that person's selfish that person's
selfless anything like two things can be
true at once that cognitive dissonance
really stresses people out yeah yeah
it's like you know even the same when I
went on trial it's like you can still be
something and you can still like care
about clothes you know yes that's being
said about women so much it's like how
is it doesn't make me like shallow evil
or I don't know also I agree it's like a
Mal Clooney George Clooney's wife is an
international rights lawyer and she's
always in you know the most expensive
clothes you can buy but no one's like oh
turns out she's just a selfish shallow
cunt it's like you know like some women
get a pass and some don't and I'm always
just trying to figure out who does and
why yeah you know I think you made the
mistake of maybe being very young maybe
when a woman's like in her 40s you're
like okay you're allowed to wear
expensive clothes now you know what I
mean right you're allowed to get plastic
surgery now you're allowed to be thin
now but if you do it when you're young
you're cheating or you're you haven't
earned this yet or something yeah
yeah yeah like you have to like be
something else before you are like
you're allowed to be
before you have to wear good clothes and
I just don't know what that math
equation is for a woman that has big
dreams that people will accept
you are going to have just seen a little
bit of an edit uh because
I I under I am now very clear on what
happened in the last 10 years your
energy your presence your no pierced
arrests Tiger Eyes
makes men just scramble
there everyone's in a panic around you
it's just you you your energy
is really myself included I mean I've
been stuttering this entire time I'm
like oh God was that a stupid question
like what if she doesn't like me like
what if she thinks that was dumb like
you you definitely do you know that you
have sort of an effect on people
energetically by just kind of doing
nothing
I don't know you have kind of an intense
presence you do have big
assassin energy like have you seen
killing Eve you do have big could be in
Assassin energy oh my gosh that's
actually people tell me that all the
time the killing ape actress yeah but
um that was like a big pick who was
going to play I've spent most of this
interview being like like me what if she
doesn't like me like whatever that was a
dumb question what are we gonna do she
looks bored like I'm panicked that
you're bored
you really do kind of um
bring out like I've seen this with a
couple people like
um were it sort of people's inner child
starts to panic because maybe they're
because you know like I have this thing
of um a lot of people think I'm a bitch
or they project on to me that I'm a
bitch because I really try to go out of
my way I'm in 12-step recovery for
codependence which means like you
basically just
you don't um shapeshift and you don't uh
walk on eggshells around people's
bullshit and I find that if you're not
overly saccharine I'm also in businesses
where people are like very fake and very
like you meet someone in 10 minutes
later they're your best friend and like
you don't know their last name and I
love your shirt I love this your hair is
gorgeous like people kind of Fawn all
over each other in a way that's um
you know really immature and kind of
fake and silly but when you're just
direct and you're like hi my name's
Whitney people are like okay PMS
this bitch on Wheels over here and I'm
like no I'm not a bitch just everyone
else is wildly full of shit and fake and
spawn all over people no wonder we're
all in a human resources nightmare you
know because everyone you know agents
male agents don't need to tell every 20
year old assistant how cute their skirt
is and you look beautiful today like no
one stop don't commenting on anyone's
appearance at work you know but you kind
of uh
you're very comfortable with silence and
direct eye contact
and it's definitely jarring
really yeah well it's interesting to
hear that about oneself I don't know
you're kind of doing a lot even though
you're doing absolutely nothing
I'll take it as a compliment yeah you're
not like anxious to get out of your skin
you're not you don't feel Silence with
drivel like I do
paid for my house
but I don't know I just it just it is
what it is to me like I've kind of like
been
I've been interviewed a lot and I don't
know it just kind of like it's only
exciting like a couple couple first
times so can I ask you a little more
about Russia sure because I'm obsessed
you know and you know there is a um
maybe you learn this in your
homeschooling uh maybe they don't teach
this over there at home or at school but
there is such a deep-seated rivalry
between America and Russia
um from the Cold War I think you guys
beat us at hockey a couple times if if
if
Russia beat America in some sports games
and every woman from Russia will pay
you know you and you know so there's
tension between Russia and America do
you think that
you know you're perceived a certain way
because you're from Russia
I'm sure that's the case I mean I don't
know so many people like sometimes
people think like I'm from Germany
others think I'm from Russia I don't
know like to me personally I don't feel
like I have two countries that you know
pretty shady places I mean Germany's
pretty straightforward though yeah yeah
yeah the Germans when they have a goal
they're gonna accomplish it for what
I've read and to me personally I don't
know you feel like from I'm from
anywhere and neither did I like I don't
have kind of like any desire to like be
able to say oh I'm from here and this is
my hometown I think like kind of like
nationalistic pride is really like
overrated and I don't know it was never
like I don't feel like any sort of
buffet I don't like I don't need to like
have any Illusions to anything like
bigger than me totally that makes sense
but I do think that like we have certain
ancestral trauma we have certain ways
that we were raised I think the climate
we were raised in you know matters a lot
I think you you know I think the women I
know are from Russia are just in general
this is absolutely you know fine as a
stereotype who cares like there's a a
stoic nature to them they have a higher
tolerance for discomfort because you
guys grew up in like a Tundra you know I
think certain things build character and
build resilience and you seem to have a
lot of resilience I haven't heard you
complain one time I haven't heard you
you know uh approach anything with a
victim mentality you're kind of like it
is what it is and I'm just gonna kind of
say the truth
which is not a very uniquely American
thing we're in America you were raised
to believe you're special and everyone's
trying to screw you over at all times
which maybe they are you know and people
tend to get attention at least you know
the ones you know that you know I can
only speak for the ones that are you
know forward-facing uh and the ones that
I'm exposed to uh taking the angle of of
a victim it's very popular right now to
be like well this isn't fair because of
this and this isn't fair because of this
and you know you seem to sort of really
own your choices and be like I've made
some mistakes but also
people project onto me it seems to be
you seem to have a very fair approach
the way you move through the world I'm
trying I feel like a victim mentality is
so toxic it's just incredible like in
special I think it's like getting worse
and worse
um I think it's very sad that it's being
encouraged it's really really yeah it's
pathetic to watch and people that just
you know have been instilled in for this
country it's a lot of you know the
religious fabric of our country there's
a lot of Shame you know just going like
yeah I want to wear nice clothes
everyone wants to wear nice clothes
you're just not like yeah no no way this
is from Zara you know it's like if you
comment on someone having a like oh love
your outfit I got it on sale you're like
well what's the you know you also wanted
it and you probably would have paid full
price too you know we're in such a
materialistic yeah you know culture and
then everyone wants to pretend they're
not materialistic yeah and then the
person having the conversation now I
have to participate in your
game shit yeah you're like I like your
jacket it's from Zara I didn't pay and
you're like okay like I don't stop
involving me and your emotional spiral I
don't know I think a lot like also it's
like you know I was being interviewed by
like people from different countries and
that's such a good indicator of
like what the country's about kind of
like it's really funny to observe
actually like American reporters British
reporters on a German French Russian
like I've done this interview with um
the Sania topchak who is
um what they say she's a goddaughter of
Putin's
um and that was an interesting one and a
goddaughter is someone like a got you
someone's your god father because
your dad was like he's great and should
be the honorary
father I think it's like I mean it's not
does that means the same thing in
America yeah it's like also the
religious the religious things like when
you go to like somebody's baptism and
you have like God mother and Godfather
like you know who has paternal instincts
Putin
you know what I mean that's the guy
if something bad happens to me I want
Putin to handle my kid even though
something bad happens to me it's just
Putin
poison me
this is only fair if you kill me that
you should have to take care of my child
and like a funny thing she said she's
like oh my gosh that's like why did you
even bother with like people in New York
why didn't you just go and like take
some money from Russian oligarchs I'm
like
you were 25 at the time you were
probably eight years too old for them to
even want to talk to you I was like what
are you asking me why I didn't like
choose life of prostitution
okay you tried to make it on your own
and build an art space instead of just
pour yourself out just sociopaths how
dare you
that was like a question that no
American reporter like ever asked me
well I mean yeah I mean
and what was your answer
I'm like yeah well I don't know I didn't
choose the life of prostitution and she
was like well well but you didn't have
to like sleep with them you could have
just promised
we could just like let them on yeah
promising men stuff in Russia and not
following through with it usually ends
well
I said I just like I chose to like
promise things to Banks instead yeah I
mean that are funded by Russian oligarms
I mean I guess the worst thing that
happened is like the guy got like
temporary suspended for like a couple
weeks
yeah
it's just tricky because it's like when
you sort of reveal that someone's bad at
their job whose fault is it you know
mine is it I mean I let me is this a hot
take that I you know
my guess is after talking to you for a
little bit and we FaceTime the other day
and seeing the way you move through the
world and you know your
passion for art is obviously very clear
I think you probably would have
succeeded if you just had a little more
time
I would hope yeah I'd like to think so
yeah I mean everyone will find out but
uh and you would have started up your
art space just in time for the pandemic
to happen so maybe the pandemic would
have been a little bit of an obstacle
but it seems like this you would have
pulled this off yeah but the the project
that's in there right now
um I mean they started doing pandemic
too so that would have been like yeah I
mean pandemic did not really like would
not have been beneficial but they made
it work so I mean I don't know who knows
it just like it's kind of useless to
talk on hypothetical so I mean I'm not
interested in that project at all
anymore so I mean good for them yeah
what do you have on the horizon in terms
of goals Ambitions next besides sort of
you know I think it's really smart that
you're doing interviews and I think the
more you talk the more people are like
kind of just sounds like she was in her
20s and had Big Dreams and you know
didn't quite
you know
um
operate from the place of fear and maybe
you know look I mean most people in
America are in debt in some way you know
most of us are living off of credit
cards and we owe financial institutions
money we owe colleges money you know
most of us go you know what's the
difference between wanting to borrow
money for your dream and racking up a
you know two hundred thousand dollar
bill with a university that you're gonna
that's gonna be hanging over your head
forever most people are in debt you know
so you doing these interviews I think is
just really smart because I think it
makes people go like oh yeah that's what
you have to do in order to accomplish
your goals forget like the personal
stuff with the friends and all that
rigmarole yeah yeah yeah I mean
I don't know so I mean what was the
question the question kind of like
what's next like what you know I just
mean like in terms of course correcting
or or
trying to put all this behind you you
know I think the more you're talking I
think the better yeah
um I mean that's like a sort of a
therapy like just doing all these
interviews and kind of like people kind
of sharing their views and point like
the perception of what they thought I've
done that was kind of like kind of
eye-opening too um you know like I said
a lot in all the interviews when I got
out last year and after not having had
access to the media for such a long time
it was really hard to kind of like even
understand where like I fit in the world
after like coming out you know and um
yeah you want to stay in New York oh
yeah definitely for now for sure do you
want to be in the art world still
um I don't know I'm actually figuring it
out it's like I feel like I've changed
so much
um I'm like um we'll try like sample a
couple things and let's see
like I'm doing my podcast I um maybe
um thinking about like starting a law
apprenticeship okay law interesting just
because I know so much about it so it's
kind of like I would hire you as my
lawyer now
like today
you have my number like you
you do have this ability to just you
know I'm just learning a lot from you
because I think we tend to try to
control people's perceptions of us by
talking too much and you have managed to
kind of control a perception by just
saying as much as you need to say and
that's kind of it yeah
yeah because I'm gonna like to want too
many Bond hearings and God hearings
do you get advice to talk certain ways
or talk less about certain things like
do you find that people are giving you
advice about sort of like how to comport
yourself or do you feel like you're just
being radically authentic right now
um oh right now no I just I don't know
it's kind of like uh
like a result of like years of what I've
been frail I don't know yeah do you
think you'll ever go back to Russia like
to visit or I don't know it seems like a
blast over there no not anytime soon
because I do I talk a lot about my on my
podcast about you know ancestral drama
you know and I think that you know being
a woman in Russia how how just from your
experience of being there I know you
left when you were 15 or so like how do
you
the old women are perceived in Russia
I'll give you my personal experience
which is that I had a Russian neighbor
uh an older man who was like 60 who one
day had uh gardeners jumped my fence cut
down 10 of my trees because they were
obstructing his View
and I challenged him he wouldn't look me
in the eye
uh so disrespectful I said you jump my
fence cut down 10 of my trees that was
my property and he was like well how do
you know it's your property because
they're zoning people there that's
and he goes well how do you know the
zoning was right
because there's uh there's rules here
you know no compunction whatsoever and I
was like well this is a felony and he
goes great see you in court
like there was impossible to reason with
this guy no shame no compunction
whatsoever no guilt and I talked to
another friend of mine
who um whose wife is Russian and said
you know in certain parts of Russia if
you're an older man younger women like
they just are not
there's no concept of having any respect
for them whatsoever yeah you know and
that's obviously you know just one
person that told me that but I'm just
curious like you know what it's like to
be a woman in Russia and how they're
perceived just general generally I don't
know what it's like these days because I
guess like a lot has changed like even
like anywhere in the world but I don't
know to be honest like I don't really
have any like great opinions to share on
that because I was pretty young so I
wasn't really like exposed to like any
of the like I didn't I never had to like
get a job or like do anything for myself
so it's like until a certain age you're
pretty kind of like protected
um just like going to school
um from my memory like it's way more
patriarchal like like the guys the head
of the family and on the man I mean um
and yeah I guess it's like a little bit
toned down in Europe but
um yeah do you have any friends in
Russia I mean it's a wild time right now
you know
um I CH not and nobody really keep in
touch with
um it's like it's hard I don't have
social media so I used to have like
people reach out to me but now like
unless you have my email or phone number
it's kind of like impossible to get a
hold of me
um and why aren't you able to have
social media I'm just curious oh well
the judge the immigration judge said I
could not why not it's just for I think
like they're just trying to like set me
up so I can't I would violate and they
could put me back in jail because
there's no logical reason to it
otherwise it's like why should I be on
house arrest before overstaying my Visa
right right right I'm just like but I
don't know
it's interesting like social media wise
is you know I started hearing about you
and you know sort of the perception we
project in order to kind of fake it till
we make it or what I mean that's what
social media is for we're all curating
this identity that's maybe like a two
percent true possibly you know so I just
think the point of social media is to
manipulate people into thinking you have
a life that you don't have you know uh
which is just kind of like fascinating
that you wouldn't be able to be on it if
that's kind of the fear that's what we
all do on social media yeah I mean I
don't know and my social media was never
really like I never used social media to
commit any crime so like I don't even
know I mean oh my like even if you look
at the Instagram from the way back it's
just it's like pictures of art pretty
much like my Instagram was not even like
that wild just like if only if you look
back for that lens it tried to like kind
of piece together that story then it's
just like kind of like makes making it
sound outrageous but like
that's a very insightful Point yeah like
if you look at it like
an isolated kind of like perspective
from isolated perspective it doesn't
really like even look that wild even I
looked at it myself and just like what
is it right right right right yeah but I
think that you know it makes us feel
better to put other people down and to
judge people and to villainize people
you know not to say that like you
couldn't have done things differently or
more like you know in a more transparent
way or whatever but I think that like it
makes us feel good to be like that
person's a monster and that person's of
this it's just like it makes us feel
better yeah yeah definitely so it kind
of like takes away
um yeah first of all like you judge
people in comparison like you know it's
like even I myself I'm guilty of that
it's just like you know like I've been I
read nasty comments about myself on
Daily Mail but then I go on somebody
else's article it makes it even worse
yeah that makes me feel better oh my god
well this person's a con artist this
person's a liar therefore I'm perfect
you know it's just like what we do
tearing someone else down just to get a
little ephemeral hit of self-esteem yeah
you know that's just human nature so
it's like as long as you understand
where those people are coming from and
also what kind of person would just take
the time of the day just to comment on
everything that they hate it just like
seems like an insurmountable task do you
feel like you've gotten sort of you know
people that have reached out in positive
ways
oh a lot I mean people who like make an
effort to reach out to me like almost
like it's always positive but
um and it's just like kind of anonymous
people online who are the haters yeah
like no one like Rings my doorbell and
tells me they hate me
there is some like graffiti outside your
house but it doesn't look particularly
negative it just I guess it just says my
name yeah yeah what do you think that is
um I don't even know it just appeared
over the weekend it just says your name
with an exclamation point yeah it's not
like fuck this horror what I've seen
written about you is way nicer than
anything I've ever seen man about me and
I did do it the hard way so I'm just
like you know you're kind of the
American dream it's just you did it at a
time where you know uh the people that
are mad at you were able to go public in
a way that was not available when I was
your age
you know if the people that I swindled
into hiring me for jobs I didn't deserve
like had Twitter 10 years ago I'd be in
jail way longer and I wouldn't be able
to be on house arrest because I didn't
own a house or I didn't have an
apartment
you know
um
so yeah I don't know do you look by the
way at to anyone
that inspires you like who are your
Heroes like who are your you know
inspirational people you know I've
looked at some of your books you love
Steve Jobs you know it seems like you
brought him up in some interviews
um your book collection is pretty
fascinating you do have a book called
conscious business which I love and you
do have the book trick mirror which is
pretty brilliant and a poignant
um you know Brett Easton Ellis
fascinating who do you look up to who do
you look for for advice do you listen to
podcasts what have you been reading
lately I read a lot of books I mean I
was in jail for a long time so um I've
read a lot
um I don't know I um like a Tessa Masha
a lot like as an author and like what
she writes is fascinating what's her
name again a Tessa mosh fig okay so my
my year of rest and relaxation okay
um that book came out like what in 2019
yeah it's a great one that was my first
one I kind of read everything else she
wrote too I mean it's different I
wouldn't say like there's one single
personal cop too just like kind of like
different elements from um I guess I'll
bring up bring up Steve Jobs a lot
because what he's done like is just
being perceived as so great now but I
had it weren't there either way those
same qualities would have been used
against it yeah a hundred percent he
would have been thought of as like a
delusional
um you know uh idiot in a lot of ways
like I'm gonna put everything in your
hands
and we're going to be able to beam
things to each other I mean it sounds
nuts you know the same way you know
people talk about Elon Musk like neural
link like that's impossible like it
sounds crazy now but who knows in 15
years it might just be available to
everyone for ten dollars yeah and like
the way he treated people like it took
there's just so many things it's like
when you just put in like the entrance
out it like ended up great what he's
created but yeah I had gone wrong the
exactly the same thing would have been
used against him but also Steve Jobs now
I'm fascinated by have he's villainized
you know people be like oh well he was
kind of an asshole you know there's a
movie made about him that he was kind of
Brusque he was kind of rude it's like
okay he wore the same thing every day
you're gonna get shit regardless you
know it's like people are like well she
wears something different every day it's
like well he wore the same thing every
day he's a psychopath you know and there
was a whole movie made about how he just
like had a rough bedside manner it was
changing the world who gives a shit yeah
like he had a weird diet
he only ate or like who gives a shit
like you know what I mean like so either
way I think people are going to find
ways to villainize you if you're super
successful if you want to be successful
it's just always going to be something
and I think that we're in a unique
situation in society where you get to
hear everyone's feedback you know it
used to be like you know as a you know
comedian the forward-facing comedian you
know a lot of people wouldn't like you
or not think you were funny you just
didn't hear about it yeah now I get to
hear about it
you know people used to just like talk
about it on their own at dinner and
there wasn't any proof of it now I can
find all the people that don't like me
yeah I think like people only think they
want honesty but nobody wants honesty
like nobody wants anybody it is true
isn't it yeah and people really want
they don't care about what you're saying
they care more about how you say it so
if you say you have a big goal they
don't want you to say like I have this
big goal like you're supposed to pretend
that you don't want it you're supposed
to accidentally fumble upon it people
only like actresses that are like yeah I
just kind of stumbled into it I wanted
to go to you know I was I really wanted
to go to college but I got discovered in
a supermarket and one thing led to
another it's like bitch why is that why
do we want someone that's lucky over
someone that worked their ass off
because if someone worked their ass off
we're like Ugh yeah greedy selfish
ambitious yeah yeah it's like that
feeling reluctance embracing something
yeah either you might as well just be a
greedy bitch because people are going to
call you that regardless
what about your personal life are you do
you date do you were you dating someone
when this happened no I was not actually
um I was kind of really like oh it was
just really so time consuming whatever I
had going on and I don't know
um I think like I just want to like
figure out what I want first because I
think like people who don't know what
they want are the most kind of like
Dangerous Ones to be around of you do
not strike me as someone that doesn't
know what they want but in romantic
relationships you're not sure I just uh
I don't know I just don't put up with
anybody's shit really sick
I don't know I mean this is fascinating
have you been on a date in the last like
five years now that's why I wasn't in
jail for a long time
no not recently I like I've been so busy
I would love to do the guy in jail you
always know where he is
you have to worry about him cheating on
you
I mean maybe forcibly I can put you in
touch
can I ask you about was there anything
that you learned in jail about human
nature
um a lot actually just because like I've
been trapped with so like many females
for like extended periods of times
um and I learned how to like get along
with everybody because you know like in
real world if you don't like somebody
like you just don't like you don't ever
have to see them again most of the times
but in there it's like you have to
figure out a way to like coexist
um and me so somebody who like I kind of
grew up as a single child like until I
was 13.
um
like yeah that was difficult for me just
like being trapped with somebody or like
with people but did you share a cell
with someone
um no you don't really share yourselves
but um you like share the housing area
like you strike me as the kind of person
that negotiated for a single cell and
got it like I was in dorms and I found
that to be the hardest part so that's
how many people do a room it's like it's
just like a big space and you just have
like loose beds I mean usually like I
don't know they're like maybe like 50
beds but you that can have like more
than 20 people or certain things it's
like not everybody's occupied but a lot
like I'm noticed everybody has like a
different perception of like their
personal hell like some people they hate
being trapped in a Cell I'd rather be
locked in the cell I don't mind being
like locked in I mean you live in New
York I know that's how you all live
pretty much I feel like a single cell in
the prisons
yeah that comes close
did you meet anyone that you kind of
like vibed with and did people know your
story for the most part yeah I mean I
met a lot of like very very nice girls
yeah and it's like
it's funny to kind of think it's like
how many like people are just people and
nobody has like a few people has just
like criminal written across before
and a lot of them are just like kind of
normal you know you would never be able
like to tell
um oh yeah well that person belongs in
jail or prison it's more like this
person did what they had to do to
survive and did the best they could with
the tools they had yeah in a really
unfair system yeah pretty much a lot of
that yeah and it's like how you kind of
once you make with a contact with
assistant once it's like it's hard to
kind of Escape that because you kind of
like once you have that on your record
it's impossible to overcome it anyway
whereas you know I feel like a lot of
guys at least in my business you know
like Mel Gibson has 14 movies in
production you know Robert Downey Jr who
I love like you know in the 90s didn't
he wake up in bed with the girl like he
had broken us and now he's Iron Man you
know it's like you can kind of rehab
your image if you're a man as long as
you like say you're sorry in the notes
app or something you know whereas is a
woman it sort of follows you around
forever and maybe that's not a gendered
thing I'm kind of just curious about
that when I find out a guy's been in
jail I think it's hot and when I found
out a woman's been in jail I'm like oh
I don't know a lot of it is like a race
thing too because it has so many like
disproportionate amount of like
um
okay Hispanic and black people
incarcerated uh in America like when you
just see like a general population if
you're a white girl you can usually just
cry and get out of it
yeah it didn't work for me but
uh but yeah
um what else to learn in jail yeah it's
was it like a it's a society on a
miniature scale and just kind of like to
see how the power dynamics play
themselves out uh and like who are the
people who like want to be the
spokesperson of the unit and it's just
like it was very interesting how do you
think this whole experience changed you
um
like in so many different ways I just
don't even feel like I'm the same person
and I felt like
and I used to think I was like so kind
of like well traveled and I knew people
and I was like in Europe and I was like
traveling all the time but I wasn't
really because just I was exposed to the
same type of person the whole time and
uh it took me like this experience to
um kind of realize
like where I come from and uh what else
is out there and like what what's
actually important do you have you been
offered to write a book
yes I was yeah are you gonna do it
um and I'm thinking about it so like my
criminal case is still on Direct appeal
so
I don't so many people have these like
bullshit advice how to make it in
business how to you know this and this
in the workplace you doing like how to
what to not do in your 20s when you're
starting an Empire
is like because I I probably would have
done the same exact thing I'd be like
yeah you have to kind of exaggerate here
you have to kind of like you know
socialize over here and get these you
know so it's just sort of now in the day
in the age of radical transparency
someone can't do this shit anymore take
it from me you'd really save a lot of
people a lot of jail time I guess it's
like I'm I'm still thinking on
um kind of like how I'm going to frame
it you know like what's the point of it
is
it's just it's hard it's like I'm so
glad I didn't write a book
um like in 2018 or 19. oh because that's
when they first came to you yeah like I
could have like done it like at any
point pretty much it's just like the
older I get and like the more I'm kind
of like I'm interacting with like the
whole outside world and like this whole
story like my perspective changes all
the time so what advice would you give
your like 21 year old self
um what advice would I give like I'm
such a wrong person to give anybody
you're very self-aware it's very
Charming I mean they have been forced to
I've been forced to be so I always like
to ask people
um on the on the podcast uh about red
flags and people like things that you've
learned are red flags in terms of like
making friends in terms of relationships
like you know I always like to pass on
to the people listening what the guests
sort of have learned in terms of how to
protect yourself you know and how to
avoid heartbreak and you know stuff like
that it could be as simple as like you
know when someone tells you who they are
believe them if someone self-deprecates
too much if someone talks shit about
their ex you know that's a red flag just
little stuff like that yeah well um
that's what actually I learned in jail
it's like when if somebody like will do
something to somebody else they'll do it
to you too
I don't know if I've learned that lesson
yet I'm like my love will change them
I can change their childhood with my
love
so it's like look at someone's actions
instead of their words
pretty much yes and it's like what
they've done to other people that they
will most likely do it to you too see
see I need to learn that lesson because
I'll go oh no they did this to someone
else they learned their lesson and
they'll never do it again
yeah that's because that's how I work if
I learn a lesson I will course correct
my behavior I've been forced to have to
and I per I assume that other people
have the same tools that I have all the
time I would say like people change
um I mean I don't even know it's like
I mean you can like say the same thing
kind of like about me
um
but it's just like it goes different
ways like I meant it in a way it's like
oh if somebody's just like kind of
talking shit about somebody else they'll
probably
if they're got if they're cheating with
you they'll cheat on you if they're
gossiping with you they'll gossip about
you yeah deck in that sense maybe like
for some more fundamental stuff people
are able to like learn from their
mistakes definitely otherwise like the
whole kind of premise of I don't know
the reform and Criminal Justice System
would be kind of be void so
um kind of like on a bigger level I
believe in people's ability to change
but like for smaller things like that I
feel like it's just it's like if you
change great but I'm not gonna count on
it pretty much all right last question
is about the Netflix series did you have
a choice in them optioning your life
could you have said no
uh so the way it's been uh been brought
to me is like well we bought the we
optioned the article and we're gonna
make it with it without you because it's
not really my life it's the article that
Jessica pressed the road so but you got
paid right
um pretty much yes yeah it was yeah
that's kind of nice so what are you
you're are you saving the money are you
gonna just save it for yourself or do
you have plans for It ultimately wow
that money kind of like went towards
restitution my legal bills yeah got it
and I guess I was a consultant yeah and
like they asked me a couple of questions
but I didn't really have much control
over the final product
well I'm excited for your podcast
I love hearing your insights you're
really um I get why I all these people
wanted to go on vacation with you I mean
I get it I totally get it like I totally
like how much do you need I will I'm
like I'm on board I'm in
okay let's wait until I'm house arrest
I'm just like into you
oh thank you like you're just you're
very self-aware you're insightful you're
profound you're humble
you're laughing at my mediocre jokes
like we're gonna get along just fine
I'm excited for your podcast I'm excited
it seems like you really just like want
to do the right thing and you know yes
well I'm definitely like I did learn a
lot and hopefully like I'll make better
choices moving forward yeah I mean you
were a kid you were 25 right I feel like
people are just being very unforgiving
and just like yeah it's like the whole
thing that we spoke about like kind of
like witchifying women yeah yeah I mean
the you know same thing happened to me
just sort of on a different scale you
know was like I got television shows
when I was 26 I worked my ass off and
people were still like oh she blew
someone for that it's like even if you
do do it the hard way people are gonna
say you did it the easy way and if you
try to do it the easy way people are
gonna say well why didn't you do it the
hard way yeah you know so it seems like
you just kind of did what we all do in
our 20s and we're just trying to
accomplish our goals yeah
yeah
I'm Indio
you'll just
making eye contact until the other
person breaks it's very powerful very
intense all right I end these very
awkwardly uh you know I know you're
starting a podcast soon I'm here to
inspire you that you do not need to know
what you're doing you do not necessarily
need to have a plan and you can just
bullshit your way through it and it can
be awkward I learned from the best
I feel like I'm the only con artist
I have no idea what I'm doing but I
pretend I do and it's worth sometimes
you know
um okay I end these very awkwardly Anna
delvey what a treat I really appreciate
you taking the time okay thank you and
trusting me but thank you so much for
having me on Whitney thank you so much
and I look forward to hearing from your
lawyers about everything I need to cut
out of this this will end up being a
four and a half minute interview is my
guess
I love you guys don't ride elephants
Anna delvey um her podcast hopefully
will be up and running sort of by the
time this comes out but regardless uh
don't follow her on Instagram because
you can't but as soon as that shuts back
up I will be the first to be obsessively
following you I'm still on it's the Anna
doll V but I just cannot access it oh
yeah well I can show you
I can
hey you can post from my account if you
want
turn to me using you
I love you guys and adelvy thank you
again thank you so much Whitney
[Music]
[Applause]